like you that concludes general
questions the next item of business is
first ministers questions and at
question number one I call Douglas Ross
thank you very much presiding officer
and can I remind the chamber that my
wife is a serving police officer in
police Scotland and let me be clear the
vast majority of Scotland's Frontline
police officers do a fantastic job under
incredible pressures
but a new report to the Scottish police
Authority raises a number of serious
concerns about systemic issues
throughout the Scotland
the independent review found and I quote
first-hand instances of racism sexism
and homophobia
in response the chief Constable of
police Scotland City and Livingston has
said this today
it is right for me as Chief Constable to
clearly state that institutional racism
sexism misogyny and discrimination exist
he continued police Scotland is
institutionally discriminatory and
racist
can I ask the first Minister for his
response to the chief Constable
statement
first Minister can I thank Douglas Ross
for raising this issue can I first and
foremost
command Syrian Livingston the chief
Constable of police Scotland for
acknowledging institutional racism and
indeed misogyny and other discriminatory
behaviors within police Scotland that is
the first step that is required in order
to then dismantle those institutional
structural barriers that exist Douglas
Ross was right to put the emphasis on
the fact that of course this is not an
inference on individual police officers
who you know put themselves In Harm's
Way to protect us day in and day out but
there is no doubt that institutional
racism exists in our society and I want
to take a moment just to say that as a
person of color the statement from the
chief Constable is Monumental historic I
remember raising issues around racism in
the police forces South clay police as
it was back then when I was stopped and
searched over a dozen times a young boy
whether it was in my car or walking with
my friends in the street or in airports
at the time and so the acknowledgment
from the chief Constable is very welcome
indeed I hope it also serves as a
reminder to all of us
that in whatever organization we belong
to we have a responsibility to also
question whether or not the
organizations that we lead certainly
this is the case for me in the
organization that I lead that we examine
and reflect on whether we are doing
enough to dismantle those barriers not
just of institutional racism but
structural discrimination that exists
for many people with a disability or
because of the sexual orientation
because they are women so on and so
forth so I I do welcome the statement
from the chief Constable as the chief
Constable himself has said having now
made that acknowledgment it's so so
important we now see action in terms of
what can be done to dismantle those
barriers and again I just end my answer
to that particular question by saying
that I take my responsibilities to use
this first Minister and I rededicate
myself to do everything I can to
dismantle those barriers of
institutional racism misogyny bigotry
and discrimination where they exist here
in the Scottish government and what I
can do very across Society in that
regard
s
the chief Constable also said this today
when an organization doesn't have all
the necessary policies processes
practices and systems in place to ensure
it doesn't happen it is an Institutional
matter
the spa report also found and I quote
significant concerns about the absence
of effective Performance Management
Systems during the first decade of
police Scotland's existence so the
problem here is wider it is systemic it
starts far away from the front line with
the management and the leadership does
the first Minister agree and given that
he has just rededicated himself to
tackling this issue what urgent action
will his government take in response to
the spe report and the chief Constable
statement today first minister of course
those in management and Leadership
positions absolutely have to bear
responsibility particularly where it is
organizations that we lead it is our
responsibility to ensure that we examine
the evidence we collate the data and we
come to the conclusion around those
structural barriers that exist that is
true for me as fastness I'm certain that
Douglas Ross will be reflecting on the
organization the political party that he
leads as well so there is an important
point for those that are in management
or indeed leadership there is one phrase
that is often used by by Anna sawar for
all our disagreements there's one phrase
that I've always found that he has used
that I think captures the issue very
well and that is that this is a fight
for us all I think that's absolutely
right I think although management and
Leadership absolutely have a role to
play that all of us have a role to play
in our organizations in order to to
confront those barriers reflect uh on on
what more we can do to undermine them I
I'm committed to working with police
Scotland but above beyond that I want to
make sure that all of those
organizations uh that are particularly
within the public sector I want to make
sure that we are collecting the data
that we have a view on those structural
barriers that exist and then of course
work with Senior Management and
Leadership right across particularly the
public sector but it also challenge the
private sector in this regard too as I
say to dismantle those barriers that we
know have existed and do exist across
right across our society taco sauce
the SP review also found outright fear
among officers about bringing forward
complaints the report notes that
paragraph 5.8 we heard of people being
punished for raising issues
or concerns that is so clearly
unacceptable that police officers who
are raising these concerns internally
were being punished we must surely all
agree the officers should be able to
raise legitimate concerns without
suffering any consequences my party has
reads these officers concerns about the
broken police complaint system for some
time it is clearly not fit for purpose
so given the severity of this report to
the police Authority and the chief
Constable statement will the first
Minister vow to change the current
complaint system and the process within
the force that has clearly in the past
and continues to let down Frontline
officers who are raising legitimate
concerns first Minister
I think it's very fair point from from
Douglas Ross we are already of course
taking forward work from the Dame Alicia
Angelini review and indeed various hmics
reports in this regard so it is that
more work we can do I absolutely commit
to responding to Douglas Ross's
Challenge and they challenge others have
raised to look at the complaints process
now process is one thing it is of course
important so important that we look at
having the correct process but culture I
would say is equally if not sometimes
even more important and that's why I
think the chief Constable statement was
so Monumental because what is
demonstrating from the very very top of
the organization that that culture
simply is not acceptable and of course
that is important that permeates down
right through the ranks but again I go
back to the point that Douglas Ross
makes of course what more we can do in
terms of the process in place I will
absolutely look and seek to do we are as
I say taking forward the recommendations
of the game Alicia Angelini review and
various hmics reports in this regard but
I do welcome the statement from the
chief Constable it's more than just
process process being important of
course but of course culture is vital
too
report published in 2020 three years on
officers are still commenting about a
system that is broken we have been
raising this in this chamber for some
time and I think this further report to
the spa and the chief Constable
statement today makes that an absolutely
crucial issue that must be dealt with
with the utmost
urgency the spa report also found that
Frontline pressures have left officers
without the time to take part in vital
training exercise it found officers
didn't feel that they had time to deal
with legitimate complaints and
grievances because they were so
stretched with their responsibility to
maintain public order
the SP report found and I quote the
greatest challenge we heard and observed
to driving cultural change within the
service was the pressures on the front
line resourcing
Unison have said that there is a 74
million pound shortfall in the policing
budget now absolutely none of that
excuses discrimination but it is a
serious problem limiting police
Scotland's ability to change its culture
and leaving thousands of first-class
officers without the resources they need
to do their job
so does the first Minister accept that
Scotland's police officers are being
asked to do too much with too little
first Minister can I I I don't agree
with that characterization and can I
emphasize and re-emphasize the point
that Douglas Ross just made of course
funding and Douglas Ross is absolutely
within his rights to question Us in
relation to our funding that can never
be an excuse for institutional racism
institutions
institutional uh
um
uh himself has made but I just want to
re-emphasize in terms of uh the the
funding that we provide for police
Scotland despite UK government austerity
over the years we've increased police
funding year on year since 2016 we've
invested more than 11.6 billion pounds
in policing sensory creation of police
Scotland in 2013 in terms of police
officer numbers of course these are
matters operational for the chief
Constable but the latest data that at
least it's compatible data that we have
that shows that there's 30 police
officers per 10 000 in Scotland it
compares favorably to 24 officers per 10
000 in other parts of the UK and England
and in Wales in terms of what more we
can do to reduce the burden on police
officers which again is a very fair and
legitimate point for Douglas Ross to
raise it we're doing a fair bit of work
in relation to the calls of the call
outs in terms of mental health that
police officers often have to tend which
we know it takes up a significant amount
of their time and happy to write to
Douglas Ross with detail of that work
that we are progressing in terms of
going back to the Crux of the the
questions that Douglas Ross is asking we
have been working alongside policing
Partners to deliver Dean Alicia
angelini's recommendations today 58 of
those recommendations have been
delivered and given the urgency of this
issue the government will introduce
later this year the police complaints
and misconduct handling Bill to deliver
on those recommendations but I go back
to the central point that I think
everybody will agree with it is so
important that the acknowledgment of
institutional racism and other
discriminatory behaviors is recognized
at what is really important is to then
work together to ensure that we
dismantle those barriers I'm certainly
committed to doing that I've got no
doubt the chief Constable is and I'm
certain whoever succeeds some in in his
role will also look to do that too
thank you question number two Anna sorry
myself the first Minister and many
others have been campaigning on the
issue of racism Prejudice and hate for
many many years and I don't think we can
downplay the significance of the Bold
statement from the chief Constable today
but I think it's important to emphasize
that it's not a single organization or
institution that is immune to Prejudice
so what we must see is not just the
words although they are important but it
must Inspire action and as the first
Minister has said that is
irresponsibility for each and every
single one of us
there is a culture of secrecy and
cover-up at the heart of this
dysfunctional and incompetent SMP
government the dodgy deal with Liberty
Steel the ferry Fiasco the symbolic
deposit return scheme even heartbreaking
tragedies at the Queen Elizabeth all
shrouded in secrecy but incompetence has
consequences whether it's hidden from
view or not Freedom of Information laws
are one of the last defenses against SMP
cover-up but ministers are riding
roughshod over these laws but new data
we are publishing today shows the number
of foi requests the Scottish government
has passed on to ministers for approval
has risen five-fold and once a case goes
to ministers to sign off or to cover up
waiting times double with one in every
six FY breaching legally binding
response times so can I ask the first
Minister what's he got to hide
first minister
nothing
Hayden is a sign of I think increasing
desperation the anasawa is relying on
insinuation uh relying on trying to
throw as much mud as he possibly can to
hope that things stick taking that
scatter gun approach but actually of
course this government has a very good
record when it comes to responding to
Freedom of Information we are one of of
course we are the one of the governments
that has the most ambitious Targets on
these islands when it comes to of course
responding to foi legislation yes they
have undoubtedly been challenges I was
questioned on this issue at the last uh
conveners group committee meeting
yesterday I responded by saying I'm more
than happy to review uh and to look at
to investigate what further the Scottish
government can do to ensure that we are
the most transparent government on these
islands that is what we will seek to do
thank you University to Anna there is of
course there is of course legitimately a
reason why ministers May you have to
sign off on Freedom of Information
requests I've made it very clear to our
cabinet secretaries to ministers that
when those when those approvals come up
that they should be of course signed off
with urgency and with pace and what I
would say Anna Sarah of course mentioned
Ferguson Shipyard in relation to
transparency and of course the Menace of
the cabinet secretary came the earliest
opportunity as soon as that written
Authority was provided he came in the
first opportunity took questions made
sure he answered those questions that
presiding officer is not hiding away
that is transparency and action
[Applause]
transparently hopeless is what people
will see right across the country
because what we pointed to was facts and
what he should do is listen to his own
information commissioner because
presenting officer the SNP despise
transparency at every turn they cover up
failure and instead of confronting it no
answers and what is going to happen to
the shambolic deposit return scheme no
answers on the fairy Fiasco despite
years of delays and millions of pounds
overspent no answers for families
bereaved by the Scandal at the Queen
Elizabeth University Hospital and
bullying investigations kept secret now
I asked the last first minister to share
the outcome of Fergus Ewing's building
investigation and she said it was
legally impossible Muhammad Yusuf has
now suggested he's had a change of heart
why because the politician in question
has the audacity to question the SNP
leadership so can I ask the first okay
the first Minister tell me does he
believe in transparency every day or
just when he desperately needs it to try
and intimidate his critics first
Minister desperate despacito
or somebody who has lots of style but no
substance comes to this chamber and
demands and things and demands we take
action
[Applause]
that's when you know how desperate and I
saw what really really is presiding
officer so let me give them some of the
facts that were missing of course uh
from his question here are some of the
facts Scotland has been a member of the
open government partnership since 2016.
in 2022 last year we handled more than
four and a half thousand Freedom of
Information requests and 86 more than
eight out of ten of those responses came
within 20 working days we want to do
more I think we should try to see if we
can improve that rate of response where
we can and on DRS which is incredible it
now seems that anasawar is taking the
side of the cabinet's man in Scotland he
is taking the side of the party that is
determined to undermine Devolution Anna
sawar thank you well
so desperate thank you for the SNP he's
siding with the party that opposed the
creation of the Scottish Parliament and
the first place presiding uh officer and
when it comes to the question he asked
uh in relation to ministerial complaints
my view has not changed from my previous
year she was absolutely right we have an
obligation in government to of course
ensure we take legal advice at where
appropriate and to make sure that we
adhere to that legal advice when it
comes to any issue including complaints
around former ministers so I will
continue to make sure I take that
responsible approach but of course I
will also continue to make sure we do
everything we can as Government to be as
open and transparent as we possibly can
and the Star Wars
presenting officer the we now have a
first and no style and no substance for
some medicine and leader of the SNP and
actually and actually we're taking the
side of Scottish businesses and Scottish
jobs and perhaps you should listen to
the consequences that he's imposing on
people Mr sarwar sorry I mean I can
hardly hear here
um those who are gathered here to
witness the session in action I'm sure
they would like to hear too so let's
just keep the noise down shall we while
members are on their feet Mr sarwar it's
all keep taking officer the strategy is
going really well just keep doing what
you're doing it's working really well
for you the SMP are taking Scots for a
ride and we don't even get the luxury of
enjoying the camper van foi laws are
floated dissent is suppressed and
problems are swept under the carpet this
is a dysfunctional incompetent and
sleaze written government feeling on the
basics and this has consequences and NHS
a Breaking Point and a cost of living
crisis spiraling out of control up party
and Chaos distracted from the day job
finances under police investigation a
former Council leader under police
investigation the last chief executive
arrested the last Treasurer arrested
officers raided and police tents and
Gardens so I have two questions for the
first Minister he says he is transparent
so can he tell us how many police
investigations are ongoing into the
activities of his party and his
government and secondly when will he
finally end the rotten culture of
secrecy and incompetence at the heart of
this SMP government
first minister
you know I I think
their politicians to leave these
verdicts to the people of Scotland and
of course they have chosen the SNP time
and time and time again to read the
Scottish government
[Applause]
celebrating polls that once again put
the labor party in second place
celebrating being a loser that sums up
Anna Sawa and the Scottish labor party
uh pretty well presiding officer Anna
Sawa said when it came to DRS he is on
the side of business can I remind him
that many people in business many of our
business organizations want the dras
progressed nonetheless of course than
A.G Barr the producers of Scotland's
national drink iron Brew Coca-Cola many
organizations many business
organizations want of course the dras to
go ahead because of course they see the
value in protecting our environment and
that's what DRS will do but incredibly
just to take a pop at the SNP and I saw
our sides with the Tories it's not the
only place presiding officer where he's
sided with the Tories because if you
want to talk about business we know one
of the biggest shocks to the economy it
has been because of that hard brexit
that has been imposed Upon Us by the
conservative government and of course
here's Farmers labor party have become
Born Again brexit years the labor party
is doing damage and will do damage to
our economy because of their hard brexit
stance and the only way Scotland escapes
the born-again brexiteers Billy B Tories
be there be the labor party is by having
the full powers of an independent nation
planning officer
[Applause]
question
question Simpson
thank you to ask the first Minister for
what reason Consultants have reportedly
been hired to advise on the next Clyde
and Hebrides Ferry contract first
Minister we are committed to engaging
with our various stakeholders in the
development of the next generation of
the Clyde and Hebrides Ferry services
contracts including of course engaging
with our Ireland communities as I said
yesterday at the conveners committee
it's routine practice to use specialist
advisors for complex high value projects
such as this one to help ensure that we
deliver a service that meets our needs
and delivers value for money our
external advisors will assist with
commercial and program management of the
project they'll provide a level of
technical expertise to ensure the
contract reflects industry best practice
to deliver a service that meets both
current and indeed future requirements
we'll also seek the views of communities
and other stakeholders to inform the
approach that's been taken Graham
Simpson
well the problem is the Scottish
government has now spent five and a half
million pounds on Consultants to advise
them on what to think about how to run
the ferry Network
we've had project Neptune that set out a
number of options then Angus Campbell
was tasked with asking Islanders what
they think what's been the outcome of
that
the current contract with calmac which
has already been extended expires in 15
months time there's no time left to
start the procurement process for the
next time the government's approach has
been all dither delay and incompetence
so can the first Minister tell us if
calmac will be awarded another extension
and is he now considering a new
operating model for how we run and
procure ferries fresh Minister
we know that the Tories for a long time
have not liked the use of experts that
has been something they've made clear
over the years but I do think it's so
important that contract on a project the
size does get in the technical expertise
that is required and look I'll make no
apologies at all for the fact that we
are engaging with the island communities
and Graham Samson is absolutely right to
mention that work being taken forward by
Angus Campbell that was of course a
recommendation key recommendation of the
project Neptune report so Angus Campbell
has spent the past few months visiting
engaging with Island communities and
fairly users and that report should be
with ministers very very soon and
although there's no specific obligation
to inform uh Parliament to procurement
competitions we will of course update
parliament in relation to decisions that
are taken because we understand just how
important this matter is what we are
looking to do is of course ensure that
Ireland communities have the best
possible service that they possibly can
and we are focused on making sure that
the current service is as resilient and
reliable as possible that's why of
course we made sure we chartered or
comic chartered uh DMV Alfred what I
will also do what I won't do is preempt
the outcome of course of the current
work that's taking place but what I can
restate unequivocally is is that we have
no plans to privatize uh nor Indie split
up the client inheritis Ferry Network
thank you presiding officer the problem
with the fire the client and hybrid is
ferry service is not the contract but
it's a ferry Fleet and the first
Minister knows the provision of the
fleet is the responsibility of the
Scottish government a consultant's
report can't cover up their dismal
failure to provide working fairies will
he now apologize for his own and his
government's failure to provide ferries
that are up to the job first Minister
well we are we have invested in our
ferry service our Ferry Fleet we're of
course going to invest and continue to
invest with six ferries uh for uh to to
to to add it to that Fleet and to add to
the resilience of that Fleet but in the
meantime we're not waiting for those
ferries to be built where we can Charter
additional tonnage we are doing so and
carmich has been a considerable amount
of money rightly so in order to ensure
that they have the MV Alfred in place
which is currently of course providing
that additional resilience on the Aaron
route a very important route for the
Islanders of course but very important
to Scotland too Donald Cameron
um the islands of mull is currently at
the sharp end of Scotland's Ferry crisis
with many people simply unable to get on
or off the island as a result of the
smp's catastrophic management of our
Ferry Network residents are up there
Wit's End especially with the
alternative route for the current Ferry
being out of service Island communities
are rightly calling for a compensation
scheme so will the first Minister commit
to this and what urgent action will he
take to sort out the problems currently
being suffered by Islanders on Marl
first Minister well I'm sure that the
transport Minister communicates with
Donald Cameron directly around the
actions we're taking in relation to the
issues that are facing the community on
mull of course these issues are in
compensation have understandably and
rightly been raised many a time with the
government and have looked into the
issue around those penalty deductions
that are made in relation to to failures
on the network my viewers that we should
continue to use that money to reinvest
into the ferry Network I think there is
a legitimate goal around the use of
those deductions but I do I I would say
that I think the best use of that money
is reinvesting back into the network to
give just one example I've mentioned the
MV Alfred already it's been chartered at
a cost of nine million pounds about one
to three million pounds of that is
coming from the performance deductions
and those penalties uh that Donald
Cameron mentioned so I think it's right
that that money is reinvested for the
benefit of the entire resilience of the
network question number four Rona Makai
thank you presiding officer to ask the
first Minister what assessment the
Scottish government has made of the role
of social media and encouraging violence
towards pupils and teachers in schools
first Minister violence is never
acceptable the safety of pupils and
staff in our schools is of absolute
Paramount importance to the government
I'm deeply concerned about the violent
content involving bullying and violent
attacks in schools and public transport
and other places where young people
gather that are being posted online at
westminster's Online safety bill could
be a means to ensure social media
companies take seriously their
responsibility to contain violent
content I wrote to the UK government on
the 9th of May
urging it to use the bill to tackle this
very issue we have produced guidance for
local authorities and schools to promote
positive relationships to manage
behaviors including de-escalation of
violent behavior and as the education
secretary announced yesterday in the
coming weeks she will convene a summit 4
focused on tackling violence in schools
thank the first Minister for the answer
the widespread use of apps like Tick
Tock and Instagram Instagram broadcast
violence Beyond playground walls and
leave staff vulnerable in ways they
haven't been before but as you see the
Scottish government is limited in its
pairs when it comes to online activity
will the Scottish government implore the
UK government to call in social media
companies to improve the improve their
own standards and sanctions when it
comes to removing material that promote
violence
first Minister yes and I'm happy to work
as constructively as we possibly can
with Duke government on that matter I
think all of us in this chamber probably
conclude rightly that online social
media companies can do a lot more when
it comes to Violent content when it
comes to hate uh for Content again
something I think members in this
chamber uh have unfortunately been the
subject of for many many years and
whether that regulatory responsibility
for social media does lie with the UK
government and very clear that providers
do have a responsibility to enforce
their own policies on harmful online
content and we will also reflect on what
more we can do even though we don't have
the regulatory powers to do so we can
maybe perhaps engage with social media
companies at a ministerial level to see
what more pressure we can apply so that
as I say they live up to their own
policies on harmful online content
Stephen Curry
yesterday his government finally
accepted the Scottish conservatives call
for Urgent action on violence and
disruptive behavior in schools his
cabinet secretary finally agreed that
urgent action not more talk was needed
to support Scotland's teachers and
pupils so will the first Minister make a
commitment today that an action plan to
tackle violence and disruption in
schools will be in place for the start
of the new school year in August first
Minister
Missy Wallace of course is an important
point and right for the Stephen care to
raise I do regret the fact that he's
managed to turn this into or try to
attempt to turn this into a political
fight I've said very clearly in my
response although the the powers in
relation to online content live with you
government I'm willing to work
constructively with them I think anybody
here whether you're a period or not
frankly can absolutely understand the
heart the harm the anxiety that's caused
to young people and the Deep staff
regardless of what our political
persuasion is so there is no there's no
hesitancy or reticence from the
government to be as constructive to be
as proactive as we possibly can and
that's why of course the guidance that
we've already issued on top of that we
provided two million pounds of funding
to support support violence prevention
activity within schools and communities
but obviously as you as Stephen Curry I
should say already knows but Gathering
evidence at the moment that will help us
to better understand the extent of
violence and behavior at a national
level right through the right through
schools in Scotland and that started in
February I'll certainly reflect on what
more we can do collectively before the
school term starts question number five
Claire Baker
okay foreign
to ask the first Minister what the
Scottish government's response is to
reports of world-leading dementia expert
Craig Ritchie leaving the NHS and his
comments referring to problems with
infrastructure and blockages in the
system first Minister I'm I am very
grateful to all clinicians and
researchers who make a valuable
contribution to our NHS I recognize very
much the expertise Professor Richie has
built up over his career we share his
ambition to improve interventions and
support people with dementia and and I
take his criticisms very seriously
indeed I've asked Health secretary to
review and consider whether there's more
that we need to do in these areas long
waits to access dementia diagnosis and
health care they're not acceptable
that's why we allocated six million
pounds of ring fence funding to dementia
post-diagnostic Support over the last
two years this is in addition to an
estimated 2.2 billion pounds that is
spent on dementia across Scotland in
2223 by local partnership that's a 14
increase since 2014 and we will publish
our new dementia strategy just later
this month and our first two-year
delivery plan will be agreed with
partners and people with lived
experience and dementia later this year
clear Baker
um I thank the first semester for that
response I do uh I'm pleased that he's
going to take Craig Richie's comments
seriously because the new delayed
strategy will be the fourth iteration
but many of the commitments in the past
12 years have seen so slow delivery or
haven't been achieved for example
post-diagnostic support and
contributions to the National
conversation on the new strategy
highlighted a gap between Scotland's
commitment on dementia policy and
people's experience of care so can the
first Minister advise how the new
dementia strategy will address these
persistent gaps between rhetoric and
reality alongside delivering any new
commitments on the strategy and he does
see the related strategy delivery plan
will be by the end of the year can he
give that as a firm commitment because
we are still waiting on the original
strategy which is now late first
minister I will give a commitment as I
said that we will publish our new
dementia strategy later this month and
that the first year that first two-year
delivery uh plan will be agreed with
partners and people with lived
experience uh this year I won't
obviously preempt the strategy that's
going to come out would be I'm more than
happy for the government to commit to
his shooting there's a full uh
discussion even a debate uh on that
important strategy I thought from uh
Professor Richie's comments there was a
number of issues that Claire Baker's
rightly raised that I think we need to
make sure we are making even more
progress on particularly in relation uh
to research and I'm pleased to be able
to say that the chief scientists office
has funded dementia and neuroprogressive
network this pathway one over one
thousand people were recruited to
dementia trials in 2122 I want to see
what more we can do in order to to
progress research in relation to me to
to dementia and the second issue that I
thought Professor Richard it was
absolutely right to raise and again
Claire Baker right to challenge the
government on his own diagnosis rates as
well so I've asked the health secretary
to look at what more can be done to
ensure that we have the data to hand to
improve diagnosis rates as early as we
possibly can for people with dementia
Christine Graham
uh thank you very much presenting
officer following the sequence of
answers to Claire Baker can I read to
the review that the first Minister
raised can I ask IT addresses the
comments by the professor that there are
tests which can detect amyloid A major
contributor to dementia and drugs which
can clear this but the government
infrastructure is not in place to
deliver either of these first Minister
yes of course that is one of the key
comments that was made by Professor
Richie again which we will absolutely
look at and that's where the research
side of things of course is so important
but on top of that we're also quite Keen
to see what we can do in relation to
increase the availability of medicines
we know there's not a drug that can cure
dementia unfortunately and we hope that
science will continue to make progress
in relation to the fight against
dementia but within our effective
treatments or treatments that can be
trialled I'm really hopeful that there's
more that we can do within our
infrastructure sure to meet them as
widely as available as they possibly can
be question number six Ross Greer thank
you to ask the first Minister what
impact the Scottish government's nature
restoration fund is having for
communities on Aaron
first Minister the nature restoration
fund will provide 65 million pounds over
the course of this Parliament to
multi-year multi-partner projects to the
store and regenerate nature and address
climate change today it's a total of 430
000 pounds from the fund's competitive
scheme have been awarded to three
projects on added the Glen habitat
restoration project the dugaree estate
school network project and the support
for the Coast Marine restoration project
all of which will bring benefits for
both nature and local communities North
Ayrshire Council have also been directly
allocated 356 000 pounds since the
fund's Inception we'll shortly be
writing to local authorities confirming
their allocations for 2324 local
authorities of course make decisions
about local biodiversity priorities in
relation to this funding
I thank the first Minister for that
answer last Friday I had the privilege
of attending the launch of the RV Coast
Explorer at wilmlash Bay and I'm proud
that that vessel was partly funded by
200 000 pounds from the nature
restoration fund established by the
Scottish greens well Marsh Bay's no take
Zone which was demanded and delivered by
the local community has had astounding
success it's a brilliant example of
Highway protecting Marine area it's seen
a huge recovery in the marine
environment which is great for nature
and Marine tourism and it's boosted the
local fishing industry species like
scalp and lobster and adjacent waters
are a bigger and more plentiful so can I
ask the first Minister how to sustained
success of La Marsh based no take Zone
will be taken on board in progressing
hpmas elsewhere first Minister I
absolutely agree with Ross Greer
landlash B is a perfect example of
exactly what we're looking to achieve
throughout Scotland seas and engaged
local community reaping the benefits
from that increased Marine protection
some of those benefits are very well
articulated by Ross Greer and it's great
to see funding too close the community
of Aaron seabed trust from the nature
restoration fund which has helped to
support the purchase of the MV Coast
Explorer so there are lots of lessons
for us to learn of course we've had many
discussion and a debate in this chamber
and I suspect we'll have many more on
the issue of Highly protected Marine
areas but I've made it very very clear
we want to engage with communities in
the cabinet secretary therefore zero in
the just transition
amongst others will travel right across
our Island communities our Coastal
communities to engage with those
individuals that could be affected by
highly protected million areas and let's
get to a place where the communities
that want to see that further protection
or in their marine environment that we
are working with them to ensure Marine
sustainability for the future
to constituency in general
supplementaries I have several requests
I'm Keen to get through them and be
grateful for concise questions and
responses and I call Colette Stevenson
officer the latest ons figure show
inflation has dipped slightly to 8.7 but
food prices continue accelerating at the
fastest pace for 45 years the UK cost of
living crisis has been years in the
making with Tory austerity welfare
reforms and brexit hammering household
incomes can the first Minister confirm
what the Scottish government is doing
within the limited powers and resources
it has to Shield people from the harm
created in large part by the actions of
the Tories in Westminster first minister
it is almost a weekly occurrence
presenting officer that whenever poverty
is mentioned we hear groins from the
conservative benches the cost of living
is still far too high for too many
families who are already struggling uh
of course with the increasingly
unaffordable cost of food the increase
in housing the increase of bills energy
bills for example in everyday essentials
after years and years of austerity of a
hard brexit that's been imposed upon
Scotland and of course a complete and
utter catastrophic economic economic
mismanagement by the Tory government in
London so we will do everything we can
within our powers for example delivering
that game-changing Scottish child
payment tripling our fuel and Security
fund providing free child care to all
three and four-year-olds and eligible
two-year-olds three bus travel to 2
million people however we know we know
it's only with the full economic and
Festival powers of an independent nation
can ministers use all the levers that
other governments have to tackle
inequalities and just to give you one
example presiding officer just the
reversal of just a few of those
regressive welfare decisions the UK
government have made if they just
reversed a few of them we could lift 78
000 people including 30 000 children out
of poverty may be and no doubt about a
presiding officer this cost of living
crisis that plunged so many people into
poverty is a political Choice by the
conservative party and the only way out
of it is by achieving our independence
Russell
Wilson
and raped by a stranger respennett then
sets her on fire while she was still
alive the judge described the 23 year
olds crimes as medieval in their
barbarity yet his prison sentence was
reduced due to new under 25 sentencing
guidelines so can Hamza Yusuf tell the
people of Scotland whether he thinks
they should apply in every single case
no matter how Wicked or barbaric the
crime yeah
first Minister can I see to Russell
Finley of course these are not metals
that are decisions for the first
minister they are rightly left to the
independent Judiciary and they must
always beat us even in the most heinous
despicable cases such as the case of Joe
Barkley that has just been referenced by
Russell Finley and and of course I think
all of our thoughts uh will be with Jill
the family affected uh Bible was a
Despicable uh crime and of course our
family will undoubtedly her community
her friends be reeling from the
barbarity of that sickening and medieval
act as described by Russell Finley but
it can never be the case that
politicians let alone government
ministers interfere in decisions that
are made sentencing decisions that are
made by the Judiciary and of course
sentencing guidelines are taken forward
Again by The Independent sentencing uh
Council what I have said in relation to
a previous case has been raised with me
as first minister is that the cabinet
secretary for justice and home Affairs
in her regular engagement with the
sentencing Council has asked for more
information around when those regular
reviews uh of census and guidance will
take place and of course I'm sure she'll
be happy to keep the member informed of
those discussions Michael marrow thank
you for taking off so this is a letter
received by my constitution in July 2022
from this SMP government it told her
that surgery for lower lower pelvic
prolapse should be completed with within
one year by order of cabinet secretary
for health Hamza Yusuf my constituent
has now waited for her surgery for eight
and a half years as a last resort we
spoke to the Press about this deep
personal situation that forced the hand
of nhsd side who will now pay for the
private surgery why should it come to
this first Minister eight and a half
years telling the most intimate details
of your life to journalists these were
your guarantees I now have two further
cases of women in tayside waiting years
and years for this essential surgery so
how many women are waiting for treatment
for lower pelvic prolapse and for how
long does he know is this another T side
crisis or are women across Scotland
suffering in silence first minister
for raising was incredibly
soon the issue of lower pelvic prolapse
of course affects many women right up
and down the country there's no doubt of
course that we of course have challenges
around our waiting times pre the
pandemic but I don't think there's any
doubt by any objective measure that of
course the pandemic which has been the
biggest shock at NHS has ever faced and
it's almost 75-year existence has has
undoubtedly had a significant impact we
are focused on trying to help and assist
those that have been waiting the longest
so our Focus has been on those two-year
weights and the number of patients
outpatients for example that have been
waiting over two years they've declined
and dropped and reduced by over 50 since
September by over 60 percent uh since
June last year in terms of inpatients as
well the numbers waiting over two years
for inpatient day cases was down 28 in
six months in fact 18 over 30
Specialties had fewer than 10 patients
waiting more than two years so we are
making progress in terms of the cases
the specific cases that Michael Mara has
I'm more than happy that he forwards
them either to myself or indeed to the
cabinet secretary for health and
anything that we can do to assist of
course we will seek to do Stuart
McMillan
thank you Daniel also the first Minister
will be aware of the latest update from
the competition of Marcus Authority
indicating that Global factors are not
solely to blame for high fuel prices
with the evidence indicating that fuel
margins have increased across the ethio
market over the past four years but
particularly for supermarkets the first
Minister will also aware that I've
raised this issue in the chamber before
with regards to Morrison's Tesco and bpe
ripping off bug constituents will the
first Minister commit to the Scottish
government to making representations to
the UK government and also to the CME
when the fuel report is published in
July to ensure that the firms are
forthcoming to prevent fuel retailers
from robbing my constituents
first minister
I will make representations of stream
MacMillan has asked me to do and can I
also commence Sherman McMillan for
raising this issue consistently in this
chamber on behalf of his constituents
there's simply no doubt that high fuel
prices have contributed to the cost of
living crisis for people and indeed for
businesses right across Scotland the
Scottish government has raised
inconsistent pricing in between for
example urban and rural areas but I'm in
particular areas such as inverclade and
we've raised those issues with the
competition and markets Authority is a
key issue for investigation but I'm
happy to re re-emphasize those points uh
to the cema as such I do welcome the
latest update from the CMA and note that
as well seeking more information from
supermarkets on their own the fuel
Market they've indicated that their
final report will cover that important
issue of geographic variation and
pricing and as I say I will make sure
that if there's any further
representations we can make we will make
them unless Brian Whittle
any thank you presenting officer I met
with the chief superintendent on
Blanchard police Yeller this week and of
the many things we discussed around the
increasing pressure on the police force
the fact that over 15 of the over 15 000
cases they attended last month only 19
involved criminal activity was a bit of
a surprise much of the rest of those
cases were around mental health issues I
wanted to ask the first Minister if
there's a recognition that cutting much
of the other Support Services is putting
an increased pressure on police time
especially at a time when they're having
to cut the numbers in the streets first
Minister can I say we've over the years
increased our spend on Mental Health
quite considerably actually from this
government and in relation to
particularly young people we are
ensuring that we are increasing the
number of staff that we have that work
in cams and in Psychological Services
notwithstanding that Brian Whittle is
absolutely right to raise the issue of
the amount of police state that is taken
in relation to helping those with mental
health challenges and vulnerabilities
now that is not great for the police and
the Police Service it's also of course
not the best for the individual that is
suffering from those mental health
challenges too so there's a range of
work that we've done through the
distressed brief intervention for
example the enhanced mental health
pathway and I'm happy to write to Brian
Whittle uh I'm sure the health secretary
writes to Brian Vettel with the detail
the various interventions that we have
underway but he can be absolutely
assured the cabinet secretary for health
and indeed the cabinet secretary for
justice are working closely on this
matter
and Colin Smith thank you episode an
officer over a period of 30 years
hundreds maybe even thousands of little
girls sent by the state to from Neti
house residential school for care for
nurturing were instead subjected to a
catalog of unimaginable mental physical
and in some cases sexual abuse today
none of the perpetrators of this abuse
have been fully brought to Justice
dozens of those little girls no women
are in Parliament today to listen to my
members debate on Justice for the Forney
survivors whilst they do not expect the
first minister to intervene in a police
investigation they do want to be
listened to so they've asked me to ask
you first Minister if you'll personally
meet with them not necessarily today but
soon listen to their plight and give
them that unequivocal assurance that
what happened to those little girls will
be properly acknowledged that is surely
the least we can do first minister
yes I will commit to meeting with the
survivors and I have met with some of
the survivors some of them are
constituents of mine have met them in a
local MSP uh capacity I'm afraid I won't
be able to do it today but I'm set in
our offices bully is to be able to find
a suitable time of course uh commend
call Smith for bringing the members
debate I know that'll be taking place
after this again I hope you'll accept my
apologies that I will not be able to
stay for that better know the deputy
first Minister will respond on behalf of
the government but in terms of his
request he's absolutely right I think it
is the least we can do that I can do and
I'd be happy to meet with the survivors
and be called Smith of course to assist
us in facilitating that meeting
thank you that concludes first ministers
questions
the next item of business is a member's
business debate in the name of Colin
Smith there'll be a short suspension to
allow those leaving the chamber and
public gallery to do so